you
hi everyone is cheering let's have a
look at another game between alpha zero
playing on the white end and stockfish
so how would a lazier ou handle the
French defense let's see first off what
variation Steinitz
alpha zero grabbing some space lending
some support to it
black undermines the white centre and
captures at the first available moment
white on the other hand and does not
immediately recapture in fact this guy
here doesn't take another step until
move 29 what follows is Knight to b5 and
with this I have many points to share
for one it's the Queen Knight who's now
prepared to recapture on D form it's the
Queen Knight who's currently striking or
I'm the weakest square and blacks camp
because the Queen night is going to be
recapturing on d4 the King Knight his
responsibilities secure a five in the
event of f6 well he's there to reinforce
that point in one final note and no less
significant than the things I've already
shared what new white piece or pawn is
now free to move because of White's last
move this guy here on c2 he's now
prepared to take one step to support a
piece on d4 this is significant okay
being able to recapture on d4 with upon
means you take away c5 from multiple
black pieces okay I cannot emphasize
this enough this detail about the pawn
one day controlling c5 ah influences
blacks space disadvantage okay if white
is able to take away a key square from
black when it's already fighting with
this space disadvantage that only
compounds blacks issue continuing Bishop
to b4 Bishop d2
this would be a desirable exchange for
white keep in mind this is blacks good
bishop
Bishop c5 is met with B form highly
committal strikes at the bishop but look
at the weaknesses left behind on the
other hand are these weaknesses that
black can exploit continuing Bishop e7
Knight B takes d4 knight c6 is met with
C 3 a 5 is met with B 5 White has just
acquired a little bit more space
they takes Knight pawn takes Knight here
we go
let's just pause for a moment this exact
thing just happened
on controlling c5
the question is how does black complete
development now if you just look at it
quickly many would say well I'll play b6
and then Bishop d7 into those who maybe
go forward with the plan like that I
have a follow-up question for you what
in the world are your Bishop and Knight
going to do your Bishop from b7
is doing nothing staring at his own palm
in the night from d7 is completely boxed
out by the pun what is his future how
does black solve this we're only 13
moves in and black is already
experiencing difficulties
what is played is Knight b6 aha so the
night makes use of b6 first to sink into
c4 and only later will this pawn move
but still the bishop on b7 the bishop on
d7 his future is uncertain
not really
good role for the light square bishop
the night he is productive he drops in
to see for
Bishop d3 Knight takes bishop the knight
actually has the choice at this stage
which Bishop to take you could take the
bishop directly the dark square Bishop
or play Knight to be form and win the
light square bishop
in the game black goes for the dark
square bishop
if Queen takes Knight that's no good
Queens gone bishop be far and how many
of you would take with the knight here
those are the only other options right
King takes Knight Knight takes Knight
taking with the knight
you keep open the option to castle not
alpha0 king takes knight in the game Wow
Bishop d7 King to e3 that's his home
he's secure here this is a rock-solid
center and how do you get at the king
look at the bishop beautifully tied in
with the central structure the knight on
f3 adds some very nice security for the
king as well
it's a closed centre play is going to
ensue on the wings the question is
basically thrown to the black king where
will you go
you're going to go queenside where I
have some space here that may not even
be possible
soon white will control the C file or
the c8 square you're going to go
kingside and compete with the bishop and
the knight that are just a moment away
from pouncing in that sector
white has space on the kingside as well
white is basically controlling this
whole board that's what's going on here
okay these two pawns here b5 + e5 are
having a great great influence in the
black position and this guy on d7 I just
I don't know what his future is
light-square bishop
I don't know what he should be doing
v6 and g4 follows h5 and Queen to g1
there's a couple ways you could look to
support the g4 point the queen is the
better one why well black would like to
play g6 here
start to control some light squares
because guess who's not around to help
control the light squares on the
kingside really this guy he's still
imprisoned he stuck behind his pon chin
okay if you could pick him up and put
him outside of the pawn chain somewhere
over here it's a much different story
but he's still he's a he's a very bad
Bishop now you can't play g6 because
it's the queen that's on g4 there's
sacrifices on g6 that would follow the
Queen sweeping in with a check so g6 you
could play if it was the rook that was
on g4 but not here
so Bishop f8 there was a punch thrown at
g7 black has to go backwards to defend
h4
Queen to e7 rook on H 2 c1 taking
control over the only open file why this
rook well I can't be a hundred percent
on that but at least you won't be
fearful of Queen a3 move
so g6 follows there there aren't any
sacrifices now things are a little bit
different with the Queen on the seventh
rank she can block a check on f7
so white now prepares to double now what
does the black King do is you know
there's two questions really one for the
light square bishop what's your future
and where's your home going to be king
it's difficult to determine so black
sets out to exchange one rook rook c8
one rook is off and now the white rook
is invading Bishop b7 follows if you
capture the pawn in this position the
rook is going to get trapped
for example chop King c7 where does he
go so he has to give himself up for the
bishop or this bishop something like
this but white wants no part of that and
instead drops back there's some success
that white just gained with this little
sequence here playing to c6
having black replied Bishop to b7 is
this a developing move I think most
would most would view this last move his
arm developing I just went from the
eighth rank to the seventh rank that's
actually an under developing move
there's nothing going on here again this
this bishops future has to be like some
kind of zig zag towards the Kings side
in you just don't even see how that pans
out but the thing is when he's on b7
he's staring at this pawn there's no
future if he's on d7 he's staring at the
b5 pawn there's no good future for him
so continuing we have King to d7 it's
tough to suggest something for black
this is a it's like Y can find
continually make improvements and black
has to take this sit and wait approach
there's there's there's no good moves
here
Knight g5 he's finally taking another
step moved 29 and with this things are
heating up on the black structure a lot
of pressure on these squares Bishop e7
and pop-quiz of the game what move which
you play here is white if you'd like to
pause the video see what move alpha 0
played next
okay well I gave you a little bit of a
hint by pointing out pressure on these
squares yeah one of these pawns get
snipped Bishop takes g6 now if the pawn
takes the bishop that's gonna run into
me let's just see what happens if the
bishops captured making three chop-chop
and we'll finish up with the cool mate
d6
okay so we can't take that guy but you
can take the night first okay this is
adding some security to e6 and only then
take the bishop so how are things
looking now what just happened here
white gave up a minor piece and only got
a pond for it
but is this really a minor piece no it
does not have a good role in this
current pawn structure continuing f5
hits okay it with f5 you can't capture
that pun it's two ways you could capture
you shouldn't capture in either
direction capturing like this the Queen
slips into g7 and it's immediately
winning if the King moves that's me if
the Queen blocks your rook watches from
the sidelines you can't take with this
guy what about this one
well that would allow Queen f6 and she's
now slipping in to the b6 square or the
d6 square that too would be decisive
any other option well let's see the game
move in the game we had rooked g8 and
now Queen h6 she's trying to get to the
seventh ranked black is there to secure
that f6 now's now hits talk about a
space advantage this Bishop is
non-existent keep in mind okay
this Bishop is not doing anything and I
was pointing out this little zigzag
thing well he's gonna have to zigzag a
whole lot more before he can maybe get
on a diagonal but then you didn't does
black have the time for that
okay let's see how play continues black
is once again having to resort to this
back and forth passing type moves I mean
what do you do here King to d8 is the
move something else the Queen backs up
Queen is slipping in there's only
there's only one move to test out here
really the only the only productive
looking move would be something like
well let's challenge this rook okay let
me just show why this doesn't work the
rooks are exchanged Queen 2h a and this
Queen is just killing everything
if the if the Queen moves
we give a check and then push through
the bishop and then the queen could
slide over here or even the king could
start to inch up like this and slowly
make progress win this pond and then you
have to past ponds again this Bishop
doing nothing the air form black
resource to shuffling contesting the
open sea file no good King to d2 is
opening up the e3 square white is
looking for a quick queen transfer
making a little waiting move first with
Roop to see one before the Queen steps
foot on III white wants that King to go
back to d8 King d8 only now Queen the e3
she's observing two key squares possibly
preparing to bat to form a battery on
the C file or I get to a3 to slice in
and coordinate well with the pawns on e5
+ f6
black rules queen a3 out but now in
comes queen c3 looking at Queen c7 ideas
black takes this as it black goes for
this idea right to get the Queen's off
use of this possibility
are now gone it simplified a bit more
but this pond can now be scooped up in a
few moves and like you pointed it out
that Bishop is not doing anything
rook g1 ties the rook down one of the
black pieces is going to have to be
responsible for this guy who could bolt
at any moment to score a touchdown so
just two steps away that's serious King
c3 follows that pawn is picked up
King before he's he's making his way
with this little zigzag thing but it's
just much too late at this stage I like
this rook a one move by the way rook a
one and only then a five white wants to
recapture on a five with the rook in the
event of pawn takes on a five the rook
wants to recapture why is this the case
well the king he doesn't want to
recapture he wants to move towards the
center he wants to sneak in by way of C
5 D 6 e 7 and guess what that's what
happens in the game it's I mean
this this King invasion first slipping
up here running around like this and
then sneaking in it's just really
beautiful to observe this kind of play
King b7 King c5
King d6 King e7
and this is the last spoof of the game
after g5 pawn takes pawn and there's
just no good approach here for team
black so I'm not sure what more to add
this is where stockfish resigns what
more to say about this game
stop fish everybody should know there is
an issue with the bad bishop in the
French defense you didn't solve this
problem and you undervalued the great
space advantage both b5 + e5 gave me the
spatial advantage allowed me to
efficiently transfer my pieces from one
side of the board to the other what good
is having a bishop on the board if it's
unproductive too weak too slow
you